[Music]
does an interesting fight now tyron
woodley wonder boy - well I think the I
think we're gonna see probably the same
thing we did in the first one just kind
of a stalemate I mean I don't know about
that man I feel like if Woodley decides
to take him down like he did in the
first round it changes the whole fight
but it but is he actually gonna do that
well he just did decided not to in the
second fight or in the in the second
round he just decided not to for
whatever reason but it wasn't like it
wasn't available to him it was really
weird and I asked him about it he said I
have no idea why I didn't take him down
Gavin Tucker it just seems to me that
this guy you know what what happened in
that fight like when when Woodley took
him down the first round he dominated
him on the ground just beat him up yeah
and it didn't look like wonderboy had an
answer look though he's hitting all
smash yeah and then the fight change
from the second round on it became my
kickboxing fight and Woodley still hurt
him hurt him bad in the fourth but one
thing that he took away took away a big
part of the kicking game of wonder boy
cuz wonder boy didn't want to kick and
be ticking down by him be smashed on the
ground like that again so he kept it
standing and kept moving back and forth
for the waist and just sort of like kind
of point fighting with his hands you
know so it seemed like it was more that
way that's how he's gonna win that fight
yeah that's how wonder was gonna he has
to keep him a distance you know I mean
his his inside game isn't bad but it's
the threat of the takedown he's got no
chance tyranian type I know and the
power exchange - I mean you think of how
how much power
no tyrants got yeah wonder who I can ask
you out he cannot come out what Tyron
can knock you out with one shot yeah and
Wonder Boy most of time it's a bunch of
shots I mean he could knock you out
clean if he catches you
especially with kicks it's just an
interesting fight to see who makes the
right adjustment exactly that's yeah I
Sam they're gonna go let me maybe do a
decision I would think just just kind of
how the style matchup is they're two
guys that seem I thought they'll end up
there but I don't see a problem we're
gonna see like I'm
every game game plan can really work
this time mmm you know just wanted Massa
do it yeah yeah what a crazy [ __ ]
sport it's just there's so many
variables there's so many different ways
to win and it's what makes it so
exciting but it also it makes it so
difficult to call like if you're
watching certain fights like a boxing
match we're watching certain boxing
matches and you know how one guy fights
know another guy fight so you can kind
of figure out what's gonna happen and
you be with reasonable certainty but
with MMA half the time you don't know
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen they have
to time it the best strategy for Woodley
be just can to continue taking him down
yes I would say that right I would say
okay I don't know I would say well he
could knock you out - this thing about
Woodley is he can do both
wonderboy can't do both wonderboy can't
take tyron woodley down he's just not
going to I mean he could he could wind
up on top if you know like in the first
fight Woodley went for that guillotine
was choking the [ __ ] out of him and
somehow another wonderboy got through it
and it wound up that it was until that
wonderboy was on top that's possible
yeah but like shooting for a Power
double and taking down the iron Woodley
like doesn't seem likely what's really
likely though is Woodley can take him
down and what's also really likely as
Willie can knock him out but wonderboy
could knock him out - I mean wonderboy
could knock people out he just it just
he doesn't have the same amount of
horsepower that would lead us exact
accuracy it spits place perfectly
perfect I didn't hit you with a couple
of them his striking is so dynamic he
can do so many different things
especially off the front leg but
Woodley's got that one punch smash power
like there's that that video of the
fourth round or Woodley connects with a
left hook to the chin and you see
Wonderboys eyes rolled back in his head
and he managed to survive that's one
thing we learned about Woodley from that
far wonder boy from that fight that
[ __ ] dude's got heart man he can take
it the fact that he didn't tap from that
guillotine like well that was horrific
he wasn't he wasn't a couple of real bad
positions in that fight and you saw it
tough he really is he's tough no doubt
about that
it's just gonna be a matter of whether
or not he can avoid the takedown and
whether
not he could be effective standing up
and avoid the bombs yeah but I was
impressed with woodleigh's ability to
fight five rounds too because that was
always the knock on him
that he's so big he's so muscular that
he's not gonna have the endurance but he
heard him the fourth yeah you know kind
of interesting what's so funny the whole
muscular cardio thing why is it funny I
don't know you're not even I he doesn't
like it when you say that he gets mad
but but it's a fact sorry
[Music]